All right. So we've got our spring with our mass and it's bouncing up and down.
And the spring starts from up here—the mass starts from up here.
This would correspond to the mass fully compressed with no velocity
because it's right at the top of its trajectory.
Well after 7.5 seconds, we've made some common sense arguments
to show that it has completed a few full cycles and then wound up here.
Going through the equilibrium position, going upwards with maximum speed.
But sometimes common sense isn't enough.
So my question is, what is the mass' position after 7.2 seconds?
The only information I am giving you is that the period is 2 seconds.
The mass starts from here at the top of its trajectory
when we're just about to release it and then it bounces up and down.
So what's the mass' position after 7.2 seconds?
And I want you to write this in terms of Xmax. So enter you answer here.
Be really careful with this π/2. Be careful with which trig function you use. Good luck.